c'est la même minute il faut vraiment
quelque chose
non tu te mur une belle photo d'un bon
vieux amoureux bien quand je risque une
belle photo de même oui et ça c'est quoi
d'après vous
et j'avais d'une petite verge non non
non c'est un orteil en a déjà fait les
analyses alors pourquoi vous me demandez
si vous avez déjà fait les analyses
telli non non c'est pas évident que son
fils est pas évident ce qui est évident
c'est de vous montrer une photo avec
d'un mur avec un orteil qui ressemble à
une petite verge ça c'est évident
une heure que je suis dessus
enceinte en fait c'est pour ça c'est
pour ça que je préfère terminer parce
que je fatigue est-ce pour ça c'est
confidentiel chef c'est pour ça je
travaille là bas aussi c'est pour ça
pour ça que c'est confidentiel c'est
pour ça c'est marrant parce que
effectivement vous dites souvent c'est
pour ça ça peut plus rien dire
1 c'est pour ça c'est pour ça c'est mon
père c'est pour ça c'est mon mari c'est
pour ça savait que les sushis de ce midi
c'est pour ça je suis fatigué pour ça
c'est pour ça c'est beau ça je crois que
j'ai besoin d'un petit remontant
moi je file c'est pour ça demande un pic
à fric pour ça il est temps là oui c'est
pour çà trois fois de suite je me suis
entendu
non je peux pas me parler là non je vais
faire une bande annonce je te rappelle
alors grégoire c'est quoi ce film dans
lequel c'est la nouvelle comédie de
quentin dupieux sais qui je sais pas
quel réalisateur j'imagine je pense ça
parle beaucoup c'est un flic qui a
interrogé un suspect toute une nuit
ça va mal tourner et un meurtre ouais le
titre de fils au poste au boss la
nouvelle comédie
2 quant à lui qu' avec grenoble unique
benoît marc 13 à la liste olivier
philippe duquesne et il plaît à d'autres
acteurs la maison amusant du méjean
bientôt son ressort
ouais bientôt 111 euros
[Musique]